la siguiente gráfica muestra una
relación proporcional cual es la
constante de proporcionalidad entre jay
x en la gráfica pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo muy bien hagámoslo
juntos déjenme recordarles que es una
constante de proporcionalidad si sabemos
que hay una relación proporcional entre
jay x entonces existe una constante de
proporcionalidad entre esas variables
que es un número por el que tengo que
multiplicar x para obtener y podría
hacer una pequeña tabla que es lo que
generalmente hacemos cuando describimos
relaciones proporcionales x y ya sabemos
que cuando x es igual a 0 que es cero
cuando multiplicamos cualquier cosa por
cero obtenemos cero pero luego cuando x
es igual a uno ya que es igual cuando x
es igual a uno que es igual a tres
aquí lo marcaron cuando x es igual a 2
ya que es igual x es igual a 2 y vemos
que ya es igual a 6 entonces nuestra
constante de proporcionalidad es lo que
estamos multiplicando por x para obtener
y bueno vamos a ver para ir de 1 a 3
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 para ir de
2 a 6 tenemos que multiplicar por 3 otra
manera de abordar esto es que podríamos
escribir la ecuación que es igual a algo
por x el número que multiplicamos por x
para obtener que es nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad y hemos visto en todas
estas situaciones que eso es cierto para
cada uno de los puntos de esta recta
tienes x lo multiplicas por 3 y obtienes
y entonces la relación que tenemos aquí
es que es igual a 13 x de modo que 3 es
nuestra constante de proporcionalidad
hasta el próximo vídeo